en efecto la misión de observación
electoral de la oea la organización de
los Estados Americanos se devuelve aquí
a Guatemala para hacer una revisión una
examinación con un grupo de técnicos y
de especialistas electorales de ese
segundo escrutinio que se tiene
planillado planteado para que comience
mañana martes a primera hora en ciudad
de Guatemala para la oea no hubo fraude
en los comicios del pasado 25 de junio y
se insta a que se respete la voluntad
Popular emitida en las urnas a pesar de
las denuncias y de las impugnaciones de
una decena de partidos políticos que
claramente tuvieron eco en la corte de
constitucionalidad y en el tribunal
supremo electoral porque en este momento
la segunda vuelta se encuentra congelada
se encuentra en suspenso entre tanto en
el parque de la industria en ciudad
Guatemala que es un complejo de bodegas
donde están resguardados todos estos
votos los más de cinco millones
quinientos mil votos que se emitieron el
pasado 25 de junio hay una fuerte
custodia militar de antimotines como
también de ciudadanos veedores
voluntarios que temen que ocurra una
defraudación y no confían en las propias
autoridades lo que va a pasar mañana
allí en ese parque de la industria no
está del todo claro ciertas Fuentes
cercanas al tribunal supremo electoral
dicen que por legislación guatemalteca
no se puede realizar un reconteo de los
votos sino que se va a realizar es un
cotejo de las actas de votaciones Es
decir de todas esas planillas que
firmaron los jurados de cada una de las
24.000 mesas de votación y sabremos el
resultado de quienes pasen a segunda
vuelta el próximo jueves el jueves de
esta semana pues Andrés estaremos
pendientes de lo que acabe sucediendo
mañana de todo este proceso pero por el
momento le pregunto cuál es esa
reacciones han tenido gobiernos
extranjeros o los mismos candidatos
presidenciales ante este panorama tan
incierto
Bueno este lunes 3 de Julio se ha
pronunciado el grupo g-13 Este es un
grupo de países y de organismos
internacionales que mayor cantidad de
recursos aporta en cooperación a
Guatemala son países del Norte global
que firmaron hoy un comunicado estos
países son Alemania Canadá Estados
Unidos Francia Reino Unido Suecia y
Suiza y en ese comunicado le suplican a
todos los actores políticos que por
favor se respeten los resultados del
pasado 25 de junio la voluntad popular
guatemalteca para el gobierno de
Guatemala las opiniones internacionales
no están cayendo del todo bien a través
del Ministerio de relaciones exteriores
lanzaron un comunicado en el que se pide
que se respete el principio de soberanía
y se invoca el principio de la no
intervención en los asuntos internos en
cuanto a la misión de observación de
Guatemala del país se dice que la
proyección es que vuelve a quedar Sandra
Torres y Bernardo Arévalo en segunda
vuelta Bernardo Arévalo dice que el
pueblo de Guatemala no se va a dejar
engañar mientras que Sandra Torres se
mantiene en silencio